[Music]
uh so I am a big believer that it's not
healthy to keep anything inside letting
our embarrassing Secrets out is like
kind of like opening a window in a
stuffy room lets the air in and makes
everything feel better so with that in
mind let's go now to a segment that we
call audience
overshare we're
sharing so not everybody is as
comfortable sharing as I am so before
the show we asked everyone in the
audience to write something very
personal about themselves on a note card
that way I can read it for them and then
they'll read and overshare about me so
let's go to our first audience member
let's do it hello how are you here step
a little bit over all right there you go
you're a natch what is it Frank oh Frank
yes I thought you said Drake no that
would be far too cool for me Frank's
cool you
know 40 50 years ago I guess so okay
let's swap this is mine all right and uh
this is yours I I'll go first if that's
okay Frank
sure it's great your show thank
you Frank you have a good energy and I'm
I'm already regretting when you have to
leave I really am you have a calming
effect on
me this is your overshare Frank I
popped there's only a couple things you
can
pop I popped a spontaneous boner in
college in the tightest pants I owned
and had to Reen scene read a scene from
Romeo and Juliet with the
teacher with a with a sponty bone yeah
you know male or female she was a female
yep still
is do you remember which way was it
being pressed to the pants or was it
raging against the pants it's always
it's always kind of jotting down left
when it happens you're a left a left
yeah hang to the
left on the right I are you right-handed
you mean like just
whatever I'm
[Applause]
left-handed you are Frank very good very
good uh Frank so you're not alone in the
overshare thank you for your overshare
would you please read my real these are
real real overshares okay the episode of
Family Matters where URL makes one last
Declaration of his love to Laura made me
cry my eyes
out what really got me was when Laura
says you know it's hopeless and Urkel
says it's like reaching for a
star right thanks
man thank everybody for our
overshare it's too
much it's like reaching for a
star alone on TGI
Friday uh all right uh so our next
audience overshare we have uh this
lovely lady come on up lovely
lady hello lovely lady how are you uh
what's your name Julia Julia yep so
Julie why don't we trade here sure here
we go sorry so this is uh Julia's
overshare one time I bragged to my
exboyfriend that I never threw up from
drinking that night we got really drunk
I realized I had to puke and tried with
all my might to not throw
[Laughter]
up oh Julia
I tried with all my might to not throw
up and instead pooped
myself and then threw
up it's okay that was horrible it's
going to be okay how long ago was that
uh six years ago six years ago yeah some
distance between you that was why I felt
it was okay to share it now yeah on TV
does it feel good cathartic it does I
feel like I can move past it now look
like your your stomach was making an
executive
decision something was coming out yeah
up or down yep it didn't really care you
choose attic or
basic well uh I hope mine isn't is
embarrassing as well so you feel better
yeah uh the first time I was offered a
I
declined there you
go I didn't feel
ready thank you so much Julie a double
[Applause]
[Music]
hug